would you like to know how to network
with millionaires and billionaires well
having now met
a lot of uh billionaires in my life and
tried to build my own
network of cool and interesting people
um i continue to get questions on this
channel about how to do that
and so i wrote down kind of five rules
that i have kind of lived by and you
know my wife jokes about this she's like
alex is the networker of uh you know
between us and a lot of the things that
i've had happen in my life that have
been good have happened as a result of a
conversation or connection that i've had
from someone i've met randomly right and
so i think that there's something to be
said for having a deliberate process for
networking without seeming like a skis
right
which is just like how can i meet cool
people and just improve their lives
while also improving my life i know the
saying like your net worth is your
network is your net worth i'm not sure
how much i believe that but i do think
that a lot of the big things in my life
happened as a result of other people all
right so here are the five rules uh that
i will share with you that
and there's two of them that are really
really good uh number like four and five
that i i highly highly recommend and i
don't hear anyone else say all right so
the first one
really simple is whenever someone
introduces themselves you always want to
make sure that you remember their name
right and so what i do is whenever i
shake someone's hand i say their name
and i keep saying it at like the
beginning of every sentence i say um and
i do it that way because i want to say
it like 10 times throughout the
conversation and it'll stick with me and
i'm usually pretty good at remembering
names and people remember that it's the
favorite word in the in in whatever
language someone's in their own name is
their favorite word to hear all right
and so you want to say it to them as
much as you can because then they will
know that you cared and you gave them
respect and made them feel more
important all right so number one is you
always remember the name and you say
them a lot of times number two you've
got to get the contact info and
otherwise like you know you're not going
to actually have the network so what i
do when i get someone's uh contact info
is i immediately text them and i text
them some sort of funny anecdote about
myself or the conversation we were just
having right and so for me it might be
like i'll say their name and my name in
the text because sometimes you forget to
save the contact all right uh so it's
like alex from mosey uh mustache gym guy
right or something like that right i
would say something in that in that vein
and then i would say uh nice to meet you
and then you know sam gamgee whatever
right and so by doing that they see i
see both names are there they know
relevant stats about me and if you want
to be extra bonus put their stuff in
there too um furniture dude whatever
right
and so that way you won you gained
rapport with them early on two you got
their contact info and the thing is is
when they look back at that text thread
later if you can get them to laugh a
little bit they'll remember oh yeah that
was that cool guy or that funny or you
know that that dude was relatively
upbeat and pleasant so uh i would like
to contact him again in the future right
now rule number three
always provide value first unsolicited
all right so this is a key point if you
had a conversation the con the goal of
the conversation should be to figure out
how you can provide value to the person
not what that person can do for you all
right it's a big one the goal and if you
really want to truly build a great
network you have to give first and you
have to give it unsolicited all right so
it's like hey i know you were talking
about this i pulled up a bunch of these
suppliers that i've worked with in the
past i thought this might be valuable
for you and honestly the more work you
do in this unsolicited give the more
people respect you and want to do
business with you and keep you in their
lives because you provided value first
all right it's a key point you provided
value
first sorry about the smudgy weird ass
camera [ __ ] rule number four and this is
the biggest one this is like my biggest
secret to uh networking so write this
down
always say yes to the first ask all
right always say yes to the first ask
the reason it's so important is that
people like people aren't going to try a
lot of times to be your friend if you
met up at a a at a networking event or
you met at a mastermind or you met it at
something right and the neck the first
ask be like hey let's touch base next
week on a zoom or hey let's meet up in
person or hey i'm in i'm in town where
you're at you want to grab lunch i
always do everything in my power to say
yes to the first ass which means that
sometimes i'll move stuff that's already
there
to accommodate
the first meetup all right because i
have learned this and i learned this
really early in my life that people only
ask once and most times if you don't get
that first ask they'll never ask you
again right and so we want to take
advantage of now if you're on the asking
side the key is to ask many many many
times right but if you're on the
receiving end say yes to the first ask
so the two sides of that one are say yes
to the first ask and if you're the one
who's asking ask multiple times because
sometimes life comes up and sometimes
the people uh that will end up being
huge players in your life later
sometimes they just get busy and it has
nothing to do with you rule four always
say yes to the first ask and rule number
five
never ask for anything
just don't do it because they'll
immediately assume that you are trying
to use them for something all right and
so if anything if you if you need help
on something and you're hoping that
someone will help you then what you can
do is when you're catching up you can
describe a problem that you're currently
dealing with if you have any level of
rapport this person wants to have a
continued relationship with you they
will usually offer help to help you out
all right and so what you can do is
don't ask them for anything you can
describe a problem that you're dealing
with and talk about it and then usually
they will they will make
a reasonable ask and this is why giving
first is important because people are
reciprocal in nature if you give and you
give well and you give unsolicited early
and you never ask for anything people
will find a way to give back to you
unless the person really doesn't want to
be your friend in which case you don't
need to be friends with them because at
the end of the day if you want to have a
network that you actually enjoy then you
want to network with cool people who you
know are reciprocal in nature and want
to give back too so those are the five
rules for networking that have served me
very well the last two especially are
probably the most important which is
never you know always always say yes to
the first ask
or ask multiple times if it's you um and
never ask for anything
uh inter from them because then they
will always see you as a positive force
of giving that is always just helping
them out and they will be more inclined
uh to to to build a relationship with
you in the future and want to do
business with you all right so there's
the five rules for networking uh mosey
nation uh keep being awesome
if you guys don't know who i am uh my
name is oxfosi on acquisition.com with
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you so keep being
awesome i make these videos a lot of
people broke and i want to be one of
them all right see you next video bye